bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
qui se situe en plein milieu de leur eau
enfin le roi a commencé donc nous allons
évidemment parler mais il y aura
beaucoup d'autres sujets puis dire aussi
de façon de parler de l'eau qui ne sont
pas seulement dont parle de manière
sportive on peut aussi on parlait de
manière politique de mavenir sociétale
on va en parler justement avec sa mine
qu'au sein de la culture interne est ici
dans cette émission elle s'y mettre
grâce aux prises notamment
donc voilà le rose peut-être pas votre
passion favorite
personnellement non amènerait plus réac
hommes comprendre que sociétalement ça
sera important pour une nation pour
l'europe de se rencontrer au niveau de
l'apparence peut être oui mais par
contre l'image du football qui est à
mettre en face où elle a été quand même
beaucoup ont tâché dans ces temps
derniers quand maman voilà voilà voilà
après ben nous on a toutes nos
restitution danser ou les enfants qui
ont travaillé toute l'année dans les
écoles je sais pas si on aura beaucoup
de papas par exemple ce soir et la
semaine prochaine
voilà c'était la petite touche en plus
de mamans mais est-ce que cela dit les
femmes regardent de plus en plus
mollement florence mer qu'à des rythmes
bonjour je regarde les sous vont
regarder aussi le football
oui oui oui oui j'avais été élevé par
mes deux fils stéphane manceau je ne
regarde pas vous avez été mais droit
dans notre jeu je conçois que ça puisse
intéresser jeu j'attends les
championnats du monde de curling
pétanque avec grand désespoir
mais le nom le voyant 10 euros je pense
plus à la monnaie mais c'est pas grave
vous êtes de ceux qui voudraient quitter
peut-être leurs auteurs north canal
football et jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour éditeurs et vous venez avec un
livre dont vous nous dites alors les
nouveaux 2001 que c'est le best-seller
de cet été c'est le best-seller c'est le
livre idéal pour les vacances le jeune
femme qui a des dons de wade au delà de
l'amour de l'aventuré de l'action du
suspense
non mais c'est un truc passionnante eu
vent de ces gens changent de l'amour de
l'action du suspense des rebondissements
tous les ingrédients en somme de romans
que ne renieraient pas les maîtres du
genre voilà c'est une chance inouïe de
coûts permet de le dire
l'auteur s'occupe de l'intérieur linguee
l'air de sandrine roy
voilà aux éditions la joie dit
absolument donc vous pouvez regarder
l'euro et lire un bon là vraiment en
même temps et voilà je vais recommencer
bouquin dès ce soir
peut-être peut-être que notre librairie
c'est alors l'euro donc on est vendredi
le premier match on en rit de cette
émission vendredi le premier match
commence ce soir france roumanie dans
des conditions il ya huit millions de
dhs étrangers qui vont venir pendant
pendant ces en hausse et semoy de deux
compétitions dans des conditions qui
font que la france 2 présente peut-être
pas s'ouvrir visage qui a eu des
inondations il ya les grèves il ya
évidemment la menace terroriste est ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne
chose ou pas une bonne chose d'ailleurs
pour la france finalement cet euro c'est
génial c'est époustouflant face de tous
toutes grandes manifestations de cette
fin d'une manifestation d'une telle
ampleur pour un pays c'est
extraordinaire et puis voir c'est
passionnant alors on veut on peut ne pas
aimer le foot ce qu'ils voyaient pas
football mondial de la voile organisée
de cette manière
sur importante en effet nommé salue tous
est ce que la france présente le
meilleur visage
aujourd'hui des étrangers non non mais
ça ajoute l euro il n'y avait pas en
compte comme la date de l'euro a été
arrêté à la france allait plutôt pas
trop mal
oui mais là ça asie ont fait pas
imaginer que syndicalistes allaient
décider de renault de dohnany redécoré
paris avec les poubelles et que voilà
donc s'activer pas conduire les revers
voilà stopper les trains stopper des bus
non mais juste par là il ya il ya un
bras de fer qui s'est engagé entre la
cgt d'un côté le gouverneur de l'autre
le gouvernement et au lond espérant que
les syndicats allaient arrêter leurs
manifestations les grèves leurs
protestations parce que le recommencer
et les syndicats qui disent on va ici
justement d'aller jusqu'au bout puisque
le gouvernement cèdera pour que la paix
sociale sera retrouvé que le rose de vol
dans de bonnes conditions et on voit
bien qu'il ya un jeu des deux côtés non
à ceci près que ce ne sont pas les
syndicats mais un syndicat c'est
essentiel est excusé dans la cgt est
sympathique il était en effet qui monte
cette capacité de nuisance absolue qui
est qui j'espère c'est la dernière moi
parce qu'après ce cri infini
il représente une raclée voilà nous mais
c'est aussi une bagarre politique entre
la gauche radicale et la gauche au
gouvernement si je crois c'est une vraie
guerre où ils sont en train de se
déchirer je pense qu'on est plus aussi
serein sur un débat de fond politique ou
la cgt et la remet un peu de l'extrême
gauche de la gauche mélenchon qui est en
train de faire la peau gouvernement
enfin sa venue comme ça aussi que je
sais c'est alors si on parle de
politique faisait aux côtés de cette
analyse la tasse et abusant de la part
de hollande qui est quelqu'un qui ait
voulu justement toujours a semblé ne pas
prendre de risques essayer de 2,2 de
croustilles et la carpe et le lapin et
finalement ça se retourne quand même
contre lui non c'est malsain où est ce
que vous êtes ça couvait depuis des
années mais j'ai l'impression que j'ai
presque l'impression mais c'est sans
doute pas le cas en réalité qu il s'agit
presque de la lutte finale
au sein de la gauche d'ailleurs
l'analyse de valls est très juste me
semble-t-il c'est à dire que il parle de
clarification cette clarification ça
fait des décennies quelles qu'elles
auraient dû intervenir
alors là les circonstances sont pour le
coup plutôt propice à cette
clarification
je moi je vois voilà essentiellement une
une espèce de catharsis et enfin on
arrive au bout d'une espèce de type de
tragédie dans laquelle va falloir que
les masques tombent alors ils sont
tombés ça fait déjà un moment mais il va
falloir en tirer les conséquences et la
recomposition de la gauche si elle
intervient ce sera toute façon après à
près de 6 après 2017
mais enfin là on a les ingrédients de
d'une techno ligue des plaques qui
commença enfin de deux espèces de
tremblement de terre qui fait ressentir
sans adresser ses répliques et sauf sans
doute une assez forte et solide moi je
pense aussi que le parti communiste je
suis d'accord un trait parties communes
essaient de rassembler autour de lui de
se positionner donc elle mélenchon dans
un coin la cgt de loterie créer un
terrain justement pour essayer de
rassembler ou de clarifier une gauche
gauche donc ça c'est clair
c'est ce qu'annonce qui ce sous tend je
pense alors ce revient quand même à
l'euro parce qu'il y avait quand même
l'espoir du côté du côté du pouvoir que
tout ça s'arrête un petit peu qu' une
parenthèse au fond la parenthèse est ce
qu'elle va exister ou pas votre avis ils
vont finir par s'arrêter ce qui est
quand même les militants de la cgt ils
ont envie de regarder le foot voilà puis
c'est quand même d'une impopularité
incroyable donc ça amuse et là au début
les trois premiers jours la population
soit un peu étonnante dans ses réactions
ont dit oui c'est merveilleux faut
lutter vive les grévistes etc
puis quand on en a ras-le-bol du canton
va presque se faire virer de son boulot
ce que l'on veut dire il n'y a pas de
train n'y a pas de métro
on l'a en plus ça se tient totalement
populaire et grotesque même le patron de
la cgt l'a reconnu le 10 septembre pas
très populaire série ne commençait pas
très populaire c'est quand même étonnant
qu'ils demandent à ce que l'on suspende
la loi elle comme hey alors il était
parti sur il faut la retirer après il
faut discuter que de l'article depuis
maintenant 10 un bon ballon suspens
effectivement comme vous disiez mais une
parenthèse pendant l'euro et puis
apprendre comment sauf que juste après
il ya les vacances donc ça pendant sept
ans souhaite mobiliser les troupes au
mois d'août mais ceux qui sont les
gagnants
mais les gagnants dans cette opération
là sont les cheminots ce qu'ils ont
obtenu tout ce qu'ils veulent mais ils
ont tenu tout ce qu'ils voulaient
absolument
ils ont une fenêtre de tir d'un loup
elle conneries l'école ne les concerne
pas c'est une fenêtre de tir pour
renégocier leurs conventions collectives
et ils ont tous gagné son cas de week
end à 12
la glace est aussi aussi notre stratégie
de dole ont semble-t-il qui est de dire
on ne lâche pas sur la loi comme rain on
lâche sur tout le reste et notamment sur
les cheminots donc la réforme de 2,2
pepy est remise aux calendes grecques
mais est-ce que vous avez pas trouvé par
exemple guillaume pepy moi je les ai vus
à la télévision stv quand même c'est une
maladresse terrible avant même d'avoir
négocié à libre on retire les réformes
qu'il ait plus aucune raison de faire
grève mais on va bien pas dire à la
télévision y ait plus aucune raison de
faire grève
savoir parler d'abord aux syndicats par
aide comme il question absolument non
pas si vous voulez provoquer on ferait
pas autrement quand même effectivement
et c'est un peu curieux comme façon de
faire bon en même temps il a pas un
boulot facile puisque quoiqu'il fasse le
gouvernement le suis pas il trahit donc
ça montre aussi l'extrême ambiguïté de
de ce qu'on appelle parfois les
entreprises publiques qui est un terme
qui signifie pas grand chose mais enfin
vous allez voir que c'est un
établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial donc
établissements publics depuis 83
c'était une société d'économie mixte
depuis trente-six c'est à dire une
société de droit privé mais à capitaux
publics et donc en dépit de ce statut
public c'est quand même une entreprise
puisque la sncf est maintenant baigne
dans un milieu concurrentiel et donc il
ya cet espace paradoxe kiki dont on voit
d'ailleurs les effets se produire
actuellement c'est à dire d'un côté
c'est une entreprise qui qui qui quoi
qu'elle dise et quoi qu'elles veulent et
est totalement ancré dans un système de
concurrence mais de l'autre c'est aussi
l'un des instruments de l'état en
matière de politique sociale en matière
d'aménagement du territoire et donc pepy
lui il est à la convergence de ces
tensions
quand d'un côté on lui parle rentabilité
performance déploiement et développement
de l'entreprise de l'autre une autre
voix lui lui susurre que il faut
préserver les acquis sociaux et que
l'innocent des cheminées qui resteront
des cheminots elle qu'il ya une culture
cheminote etc
donc c'est pas simple pour peppy et je
crois qu'en plus il ya eu une sorte de
bras de fer entre lui évidemment le
gouvernement est menacé de démissionner
que je crois que ça le soit disant un
successeur si il est resté cdu on parle
de foot à pompe a alors deux
pour sabine est ce que vous pensez de
jeu revient au même la même
problématique si
jamais la france fait un très bon euro
qu'elle gagne est ce que vous pensez
quand même dit c'est pas un moyen comme
de rassembler un peu les gens derrière
la butte quels qu'ils soient je sais pas
votre favorite mais mais mais on peut
après tout ça fait un signe de
ralliement et de rassemblement c'est
l'un des épisodes enfin c'est encore une
fois que je le cite souvent parce que
j'aime beaucoup ce qui fait un rose en
valant pierre rosanvallon qui dit le
peuple est introuvable c'est une espèce
d'entité la nation ce pareil c'est
quelque chose de très abstrait sauf que
parfois certains épisodes de l'actualité
l'histoire on aperçoit le peuple et la
nation alors notamment 80 18 sur les
chances existent c'était ça le peuple
aussi est donc là j'ai vu en arrivant
quelques drapeaux français au bahreïn
alors je me doute que l'on sait c'est
plus pour les les attentats je pense que
c'est pour la compétition qui commence
et de ce point de vue là je trouve que
c'est assez heureux plutôt pas mal et
alors il ya eu hier je rappelle qu'on
est con orgie cette émission le vendredi
10 juin
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui hier ça
serait faire part pas forcément la date
de diffusion
il ya eu ce grand concert sur la sur
l'esplanade de la tour eiffel et le
champ-de-mars et on en a vu qui avait 81
ans plus de grain une personne qui sont
venus donc un énorme succès quand même
malgré les mises en garde les mises en
cause de ses fans zone
le matin même nicolas sarkozy je crois
sur europe1 lisez moi en tant qu'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur je suis contre
les femmes zone c'est dangereux et on
voit au fond que les gens malgré les
risques et qui sont là qui existent
passe outre ils y vont il faut ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire comme envie d'être
ensemble ils ont vite réagi quelque
chose ensemble je pense que ça
correspond bien à tous qu'on soulève
comme question là c'est le vivre
ensemble partager quelque chose on en a
besoin de deux séries d'attentats
gravissime
voilà tout 7,7 est urgent on aurait pu
penser qu'il y avait le peuple oui mais
bon c'est jean le bitoux certains qui
suivent complètement tout ce que vous
dites qu'ils vont pas y aller
il me restait dangereux bandits n'ont
même pas comme ça que vous êtes en droit
de se poser comme question là et puis en
a d'autres qui ont envie de partager
quelque chose mais voilà alors c'est
peut-être laissé dans we celle là semble
plus forte que nous
donc j'espère que tout se passera bien
mais ça je peux le comprendre sans
aucune difficulté moi c'est juste que
vous me demandez je sais pas quel est le
favori ou qui en aura pas de vous dire
quoi que ce soit moi je vous aide pour
la roma je coupe le sens intelligence
intelligence jeu quand on coupe le son
ne sont pas bien les attaquants comment
il montera mature gît dans un match de
foot qui est extraordinaire qu'on n'a
pas souvent dans les salles de théâtre 1
3 de sa formidable au monde
mélanie bridge dit non ce n'est pas un
théâtre c'est un combat c'était entre
sais pas c'est pas ou fait pas semblant
on est pour donner pour de vrai et est
formidable c'est que vous l'avez vu cet
arrêt nous sommes ici quand il parle de
hollande je peux leur pour l europe
populaire mais je sais pas si j'en ai
envie
non mais c'est vrai alors est ce qu'on
n'a pas cependant je reviens à ce que je
disais avant un septembre un peu décousu
après tout mais est ce qu'on n'a pas au
fond intégrer
dans nos vies la menace terroriste en se
disant qu'après tout bon advienne ce qui
adviendra qu'on peut pas empêcher des
dingues de se faire sauter avec une
ceinture d'explosifs et que voilà où il
faut vivre quand même et faire les
choses vont à faire malgré tout des gens
le peuple français les français puis les
autres n'y a pas qu'en france 4,6 menace
là je pense qu'on défend d'une façon ou
d'une autre un monde de liberté ou n'a
pas envie de se laisser faire quand même
quelques temps c'est ce qui se passe en
israël où ils y passent leur temps aux
terrasses des cafés et la situation
comme beaucoup plus risquées et
dangereuses
jérusalem ou dans n'importe quelle ville
israélienne qu à paris bien évidemment
mais ils passent leur temps à sortir à
faire la fête à boire etc sachant très
bien que le risque est là elle est
énorme mais ils continuent ils ont pas
peur et je pense que le concert qu'elle
faisait allusion c'est un peu la même
démarche
la majorité des gens ne nie pas du tout
la menace terroriste
maintenant il ya mal de toute façon on
n'y peut rien donc voilà si ça doit
arriver des grains wittmann de la part
des sociétés de sécurité des gens qui
sont chargés en fin de tout ça concourt
l'air de dire voilà il peut arriver
quelque chose et peut-être que peut-être
que cela dit le la réaction des joueurs
changerait si par malheur
en même temps j'ai autant la situation
s'améliore considérablement puisque ils
ont découvert quand même 92 type fichier
s dans les responsables de la sécurité
du du foot quand même quatre jours avant
l'ouverture de l'euro ces gens se
demander à quoi servait des fiches
est ce enfin quatre jours avant on sent
ça sert à quelque chose qui m'inquiète
c'est extraordinaire les jeux du stade
c'est pas bien mais certains c'est ce
qu'on veut
autrefois mais donc vous n'avez pas de
favori soufflante
vous n'êtes même pas pour la france non
mais non je suis une française mais
c'est juste que je sais pas favoris j'ai
pas un avis avisé donc je vais pas me
mettre à parler de trucs que voilà je
vous la laisse lapin surtout si vous
avez envie
ce serait bien oui ce serait bien que la
france gagne mais j'en suis pas tout à
fait convaincu
enfin je
voilà ce serait bien mais je ne suis pas
convaincu il des défections par des
blessures et tout simple de match on
n'est pas voir un pronostic mais non
suis sûr qu'ils vont aller au moins en
demi finale mais oui oui mais voilà
quant à lui car il normal
normalement il n'y a pas de raison de
paniquer ce qu'on ait au moins jusqu'en
demi finales après il ya les prêts il
reste deux matches mais je vois l'équipe
de france gagner l'euro c'est bien beau
mais ça n'aura pas donc le 11 juillet
l'islande a huy belgique à les diables
rouges entendu là le rouge pour toi et
ton et gardien hors pair bien sûr mais
d'hazard mais cela dit d'islande
les enfants méfiez-vous l'a vraiment
kivu le défilé et la salade il n'avait
pas tort parce que je veux c'est cette
réflexion en moi même et in petto non
c'est vrai si vous comprenez l'année
l'année footballistique pardon heureuse
pas forcément mais qui aurait dit que
platini ne terminerait pas je ne serais
même pas présent à l'uefa que c'est pas
idée des zidane gagnerait comme
entraîneur la ligue des champions que
l'inceste leicester champion
d'angleterre à des données wii u
absolument toutes les surprises
inimaginable donc il n'ya pas de raison
que ça continue donc l'islande
non donc l'islande quota de surprise
donc il a appâté appris de l'apprendre à
gagner et l'islande le restera une une
petite nation du football et sans donc
michel platini qu'il sera pas là voilà
les massues suis un petit peu étonné
j'ai rien contre platini est sûrement
très sympathique il est un très bon
joueur c'était un bon joueur c'est avec
beaucoup de choses
non mais en tant que patron je suppose
que tu appelles n'est donc pas trop de
l'uefa comme joueur excellence et l
autre raison il avait la fille en
vignettes panini de sable et vous l'avez
montré
c'était leur bible c'était l'entraîneur
de l'équipe de france en 1984 de son
petit quand nous avons et puis mes b en
tout état de cause et là je tout le
florence devrait nous donner son avis il
a quand même été jugé et écarté de toute
responsabilité dans le monde du foot et
alors comme c'est un titre qui a
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis d'abord ça
avait commencé quand il a eu ses ennuis
judiciaires par manuel valls qui a dit
je soutiens platini se connaissant pas
le dossier le soutenait bon c'est quand
même assez curieux et puis là maintenant
il était condamné il n'a plus le droit
de se pointer dans un stade de foot mais
à longueur de 2 d'émissions de télé et
de d'émissions de radio tout le monde
est là pour regretter pour dire mais mes
voeux platini est tellement bien
tellement sympa et c'est tant mieux vaut
platini mais je regrette qu'un voleur de
mobylette n'ai pas droit la même
mansuétude quater lui il prend un
million trois cent mille euros
et tout le monde vibre c'est merveilleux
c'est pas grave moi c'est sale ça me
choque n'en va pas regretter que je
regrette qu'il ait vu qu'il est mal agi
avec un million trois cent mille euros
c'est ça que je regrette que la femme
n'est de ne pas juger définitivement
mais non vous aidiez à poney mais je
suis intervenu sur quoi surtout parce
que encore des recours il ya main mais
que c'est vrai
choquant il a pâti de particuliers mais
il veut y aller oui dans le public il
peut dès maintenant on peut être invité
il n'a plus aucune fonction officielle
mais quelle décision il viendra pas
c'est pour ça que je n'aurais deux
personnes que je n'attaque pas c'est
votre ami béroud et puis votre avis
platini donc je ne sais pas platini que
j'attaque sté des journalistes qui
passent leur temps à virale c'est
platini ce serait tellement bien s'il
était là oui mais il a fauté il s'est
fait attraper bon respect des
journalistes respectent pas les microbes
qui n'existe pas les journalistes ils
ont le droit d'estimer qu' il n'est pas
là il pourra porter il a divisé mais
c'est pas très bon chef fantastique
c'est un beau problème du grand est ce
que je peux regagner alors dans la
situation sociale puisque jusque c'était
de la comparer les 2 7 euros dans cette
situation un peu tendue sur ce fameux
article 2 de la loi elle comme riz au
fond et est-ce que c'est pas ça est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une vraie coupure puisque
on parlait tout à l'heure des deux
gauches kilkis qui sont en rupture
aujourd'hui est-ce que tout n'est pas
dans cet article 2 c'est à dire que d'un
côté il ya la gauche étatique qui dit au
fossé l'état et c'est peut-être les
branches qui est visé aux supérieurs aux
entreprises etc
enfin c'est au fond d'attentes solution
détails de la loi et une gauche qui est
la social démocratie pour laquelle cinq
ans les huit qui est plus pour la
négociation et qui voudrait que ce soit
pas l'état qui fasse tout mais que les
gens se débrouillent par dell
négociations à l'interprète est ce que
tout n'est pas au fond dans cet article
de sk pas la coupure entre les yeux de
gauche
bah oui oui mais c'est très intelligent
patrice mais à ce que je trouve tout à
fait regrettable mais pour allait même
plus loin de 2 par rapport à votre
réflexion c'est que cet article 2 ouvre
la porte des entreprises à 2 rappelons à
oui alors l'article 2 permet l'article
insectes active alors marty première
c'est qu'on parle de la rue que deux je
pense dans une enceinte ans marc au
pathé je veux tout d'abord jusqu'à
présent son départ et personne alors
l'article 2 précise le fait que dans que
par accord d'entreprise on peut déroger
à l'accord de branche de manière
défavorable aux salariés
bon alors si je le fais court que ça
simplement c'est par accord d'entreprise
ce qui veut dire qu'un accord
d'entreprise doit passer par le prisme
de syndicats notamment dans les grandes
entreprises il faut signer avec les
partenaires sociaux et avec les
syndicats dans les entreprises plus
petites sur la durée du travail
notamment on peut signer mais avec les
représentants du personnel et délégué du
personnel ou les comités d'entreprise
donc ça veut dire qu'on va signer avec
des élus salariés ou avec des syndicats
et je trouve que cet article permettait
justement je crois que c'est ce que la
cfdt a compris est ce que ne veut pas
comprendre la cgt mais pour des raisons
qui me semble aussi assez clair c'est
que là on ouvrait la porte des
entreprises pour les syndicats pour les
représentants du personnel pour signer
des accords au niveau des entreprises et
faire en sorte qu' on puisse adapter des
accords de branche peut être de façon
défavorable par rapport à la branche qui
est qui est au dessus mais favorable à
l'entreprise et à la relation salariée
et activités de l'entreprise et
employeurs et je trouve tout à fait
dommage que les syndicats alors à part
la cfdt qui lui est d'accord elle n'est
d'accord avec le texte tel qu'il est la
cgt n'est pas d'accord mais parce que la
cgt c'est 3 % des salariés du privé
qu'elle ne représente rien qui étaient
extraits
mon faible parce qu'aussi aide les
membres de la cgt les délégués syndicaux
ou un certain âge mais c'est vrai qu'on
a cette problématique là ils n'arrivent
pas à recruter sur des jeunes délégués
syndicaux de la cgt
et donc ils se disent on n'a pas les
moyens humains pour pouvoir rentrer dans
les entreprises et donc on va se faire
griller la place dans les entreprises
par d'autres syndicats et donc on va
être contre et je trouve ça tout à fait
regrettable parce que là le syndicalisme
et les élus retrouver une place et le
fait de le que le sein de la cgt 10
mais non les salariés ils vont rien y
comprendre ils vont se faire avoir
ils vont être roulés dans la farine il
ya une espèce de de défiance de la pause
lancé par la cgt aux salariés dont vous
attendez vous êtes des incapables et
vous saurez pas faire donc vous allez
vous tout sera défavorable et ce sera
pas bon pour vous je trouve ça tout à
fait regrettable qu'ils n'aient pas
saisi la balle au bond justement pour y
aller et essayer de peut être de
négocier autre chose dans le cadre de
l'article 2 peut-être de dire si on fait
un accord si on signe un accord plus
défavorable et ben demandons de
l'homologation au dessus de la branche
des commissions paritaires il y avait
moyen de faire autrement plus tôt que
tout bloquer tout verrouillé et voilà tu
pas si c'était très clair
parfait en ciel parfaitement clair avant
de poursuivre propose justement de voir
un extrait eu un débat dans le 7-8 de tv
fil entre représentants du medef
un représentant du parti communiste et
en représentant de la cgt
les patrons mais ils sont atterrés
aujourd hui sont atterrés il faut bien
savoir quand même que aujourd'hui tous
les mouvements sont des mouvements de
façade
la loi elle connerie ne les touche pas
quand on parle la sncf de l'aider est
fédéral n'y a quasiment rien on est sur
une défense de posture cette loi c'est
une loi de régression sociale
c'est pas une oie travail c'est une loi
de précarisation du travail et donc
c'est dans ce sens là qu'il ya des
solidarités qui s'exprime parce que tout
le monde sait très bien que par delà
cette loi ça touchera d'autres secteurs
d'activité aujourd'hui le sujet il est
simple c'est que moi je demande
solennellement grévistes de la sncf
par esprit de solidarité et avec 70
parlementaires de toute l'ile-de-france
tous les parlementaires des yvelines le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines
je demande de suspendre la grève parce
qu'on ne peut pas ajouter de la galère à
la galère moi je suis amusé à chaque
fois qu'il ya un mouvement voix de grève
des mobilisations de salariés ben oui on
redécouvre que ceux qui font les
richesses que ceux qui font fonctionner
le pays que ceux qui font rouler les
trains qui font tourner les magasins ou
autres
bah oui ce sont ce sont les salariés
vous nous dites voilà le ce sont les
entrepreneurs qui font le pays sans
salarié il ya ya ya rien qui fonctionne
et on s'en rend compte des colonnes le
cgt alors on voit bien la face et c'est
assez typique ce débat se dire que c'est
un dialogue de sourds crise et tout le
monde travaille avec c'est à nouveau un
décompte absolument pas l'eau prisé
surtout pas ce qui se passe ici
les présidents séances ouvertes serait
l'un des derniers là mais c'est promis
volante
ces classes patrice une formidable il
s'amusait dangereux non sa pipe est un
drone vous avez des news ou au prisme
zouk
oui oui messieurs basque est formidable
et je faisais un enfant d où vas-tu
petit de fourmies tu vas à l'école c'est
génial et extra est ce que vous vous
souvenez du moment où vous avez passé le
bac
oui moi je me souviens des moments oui
on a eu à la septième fois a donné l
époque l époque on ne donnait pas comme
ça eh ben on va on va regarder un sujet
sur les surtout ceux que l'on pend au
cal ont pensé qu'ils qui passent le bac
c'est lundi non je sais pas du tout
voilà c'est probable oui oui c'est ça
faisait respirer l'enseignement
supérieur sujet donc la préparation du
bac
florian 17 ans prépare un bac général
scientifique
à deux semaines de la première épreuve
il est en pleine révision
j'essaie de faire plus tôt par semaine
je mets plusieurs matches dans la
semaine et je me suis dit je fais des
fils de révision à partir des chapitres
est donc comme ça je vous lis les fiches
de révisions et ça rentre en tête après
chaque session de révision il n'oublie
pas de se détendre et va jouer au foot
entre copains ou avec son club l'étoile
sportive de trappes la part du temps
quand je donne des cours je mange
ensuite je révise le plus possible avant
le foot ensuite j'ai moins traîner si en
rentrant j'ai encore un peu de
motivation que le lendemain j'ai une
épreuve important de balle les accords
même rythme pour mamadou 19 ans il
présente un bac professionnel technicien
du froid et du conditionnement de l'air
quand il ne révise pas chez lui c'est au
cap à dos de magny les hameaux qu'il
s'isole avant de rejoindre famille et
amis pour jouer conférerait tout seul
pour être dans le calme
pour pour me sentir un peu seul pour
mettre en retrait un peu un peu et c'est
mieux c'est mieux comme ça aussi d'être
dans le calme depuis j'ai reçu les
convocations du bac j'ai commencé à
réviser et les profs on nous a dit rossi
on va commencer à réviser et et quand
j'ai fini mes épreuves d'ateliers et de
maths et de physique j'ai commencé
directement à réviser florian vise la
mention assez bien accessible à partir
d'une moyenne de 12 sur 20 s'il devient
bacheliers mamadou espère entrer en bts
verdict le 5 juillet prochain date des
résultats
l'an dernier près de 88% des candidats
obtenaient le baccalauréat général dans
la filière professionnelle
le taux de réussite était de 91 5%
88 % l'année dernière c'est beaucoup
quand ma main ça commence à faire
beaucoup d'autant que j'avais moins 7 et
80% a cédé 82 voyez là c'est totalement
débridée et ça commence à faire beaucoup
d'autant qu'après il y en a quand même
pas mal qui souhaitent se diriger vers
les études universitaires et que ça fait
beaucoup de monde à accueillir avec
moins de sous on dirait tout n'est pas
question d'argent et plaie d'argent
n'est pas mortelle
d'accord mais sauf les l'argent n'est
pas mort table oui je voulais dire
mais abbey pour que les universités
puissent avoir un peu de quoi accueillir
dignement les étudiants ce qui est
parfois pas ça va être très compliqué il
ya eu par exemple en maintenant enfin la
rentrée universitaire dernière pas ici
mais dans toute la diversité française
quarante mille étudiants plus pour avoir
une idée 40 mais l'étudiant ça
représente à peu près deux universités
de taille moyenne et jusqu'à 2000 je
crois 2021 et 2022 il va falloir en
accueillir à peu près à ce rythme là
tous les caisses que voulez vous appuyez
longtemps non il y en a beaucoup on la
reverra d'après c'est un énorme gâchis
et apparemment ça convient à tout le
monde donc continuer encore c'était ça
que je
une sorte de mensonges france et là
encore ce que je crois sélection
sélection elle se fait à un moment mais
la sélection n'y a que cela je connais
certains syndicats sélection ne la fait
pas au bac on la vieille pas bien sûr et
pour pourquoi est ce que en première
année on a on à la fac de droit on a 600
ou 700 inscrits et que arrivé en 3ème
année ils sont plus de 300 ours qui sont
passés ça s'appelle la sélection alors
c'est vous la sélection sur le mérite
c'est parfait face à moi ça ne me choque
pas bien au contraire
sauf que ce système là en effet est une
hypocrisie sans nom mais c'est aussi un
système très coûteux parce que ça coûte
très cher
en attendant d'accueillir beaucoup
d'étudiants qu'on va garder pendant un
an alors voire plus parfois et qui ne
parviendront pas à s'en sortir
donc c'est pas grave il ya de l'argent
partout donc pacino et qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire mon brave monsieur
ce qu'il faudrait faire dans ce qu'il va
faire basculer est ce que l'idée parce
que 10 des 80 % d'une classe d'âge
quel bac c'est à dire en gros d'élever
le niveau moyen c'était c'était plutôt
sur le papier de bonnes idées ça reste
une bonne heure il manie le l'objectif
aussi qu'on poursuit c'est 50 % d'une
classe d'âge à bac +3 à lons grade de
licence alors en soi c'est aussi une
bonne idée parce que on parlait de
compétitivité tout à l'heure il n'y a
pas que sale ça compte aussi
ça fait partie de des éléments de
compétitivité d'un pays d'un état dans
le monde
mais ce qu'il faudrait faire ce qu'il
faudrait faire il faudrait faire
beaucoup de choses mais ça pourrait
faire l'objet d'une émission soit seul
je ne vais pas si vous aimez bien engagé
sur ce sujet mais on y reviendra
mais c'est en effet c'est en effet une d
hypocrisie française enfin ça c'est
d'une hypocrisie d'autant que d'autant
que tous ceux qui ont le bac ne sont pas
égaux si je puis dire puisque après il
ya les mentions il ya les vacances
j-1 fessionnels jaya des différences
énormes au sein des bacs généraux il ya
aussi commence à y avoir des différences
assez forte
et puis on les lit c'est aussi dès
qu'elles sortent les diplômés sont aussi
assez déterminant enfin bon voilà le
système fonctionne qu'est ce que c'est
ça avec 80 % de reçus ce que c'est pas
encore plus de traumatisant pour ceux
qui ne l'ont pas parce que on dire on a
des retards mais considérés comme des
crétins absoluce qubo forcément le cas
enfin je ne sais pas mais c'est pas
c'est pas tant une question que le
niveau baisse que tout ça parce que on
parvient à ce chiffre
en élargissant s'ils voulaient la masse
des bacheliers avec notamment les bacs
professionnels qui qui qui n'ont cessé
de fleurir depuis les 30 dernières
années
bon les bacheliers globalement sont pas
sont pas d'un niveau scandaleux du moins
pas tout jouer et globalement je pense
que l'examen est utile parce que c'est
la première fois que les lycéens sont
soumis un type d'épreuve qu'ils auront à
reproduire qu'il soit par la suite dans
un système dit de grande école ou un
système universitaire c'est comme ça que
ça marche donc c'est un bon entraînement
me semble-t-il mieux que mieux car
contrôle continu on peut on peut essayer
d'équilibrer ce qui a tendance à se
faire et après je pense que les 12% qui
n'ont pas le bac sont tous des gens qui
montrent qu'ils sont inadaptés au milieu
scolaire et une certaine forme
d'enseignement parce qu'après énormément
de gens qui
parmi ce qu'on peut leur bac qui
arrivent par des filles est attrayante à
refaire des études supérieures et qu'ils
se démerdent pas bien dans leur étude
perd donc très souvent ça se passe et
c'est plus souvent le signe parce que
c'est vrai que ce que ce que vous disiez
que quand on voit quand même sur les 88
% de gens qui ont leur bac
mais là on se dit c'est curieux qu'ils
aient eu leur bac face du terrain c'est
étonnant donc voila c
c'est plutôt une conformité à un modèle
et une façon de faire qu'une vue que des
capacités je pense c'est vrai qu'on peut
devenir président du conseil
constitutionnel sans avoir eu son bac
par exemple aujourd'hui devrait way jean
louis debré et est capacitaire en est
resté endroit j'ai hésité mais après
voilà de permis auprès de devenir
magistrat pasqua ensuite il a pris des
études de droit des droits sur les sites
o'reilly un monde peut-être peut-être
allez-vous florent sur la faire car
viennent exposer tous été un peu étonné
donc il a été condamné plusieurs fois
pénalement
même si
beaucoup de gens soutiennent la thèse
selon laquelle c'est pourrait penser
qu'ils n'étaient pas seuls dans cette
affaire est que et que les gens la
société générale savait quels étaient
ses agissements mais là le les
prud'hommes ont condamné la société
générale et à verser en plus une somme
assez importante
j'ai en tout cas rien de 450000 euros je
crois il y appelle général a fait appel
mais on est un peu quand même
au dire voilà est-ce que c'est pas un
retournement judiciaire dans cette
affaire kerviel
alors je pense que ça va pouvoir lui
être très utile lors de la plaidoirie la
semaine prochaine devant la cour d'appel
de versailles puisque la cour de
cassation avait cassé la décision à leur
passion plan pénal parce qu'il est
condamné pénalement définitivement mais
il à la cour de cassation a renvoyé à la
cour d'appel de versailles sur la
problématique des intérêts civils et de
magenta à elle été condamnée à 5
milliards ailleurs la société générale
voilà pas simple et là ce jugement
extrêmement bien motivés il faut alors
c'est dommage parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'explications pédagogiques mais comme
d'habitude quoi donc sur la visite à la
salle condamnée fin d'année alors on dit
à l'ats il effectivement globale non ça
donne quatre cent cinquante mille euros
mais sur ces quatre cent cinquante mille
euros
il a eu trois cent mille euros de bonus
qui lui sont dues depuis 2007 c'est à
dire que sur l'année 2007 il a fait
gagner un peu plus d'un milliard d'euros
la société générale ce qui déclenche un
bonus de trois cent mille euros que la
société générale avait reconnu lui lui
devoir et au moment comme il a été
licencié en 2008 ils ont bloqué ils ont
pas payé ses trois cent mille euros donc
déjà sur les 456 à 300000 euros qui
correspondent à des bonus qui lui sont
dus de façon assez incontestable et sur
les cent cinquante mille euros qui
restent il ya cent mille euros de
dommages-intérêts pour licenciement et
je vais expliquer peut-être pourquoi sur
un licenciement sans cause réelle et
sérieuse qui correspond à 11 mois de
salaire puis après il ya son préavis
congés payés sur préavis indemnités de
licenciement c'est un peu de cette
façon-là dont se dispatchent cette somme
est pourquoi est ce que le conseil des
prud'hommes a estimé que licenciement
était sans causes réelles et sérieuses
parce qu'il a estimé que la société
générale connaissez les agissements de
jérôme kerviel depuis le courant de
l'année 2007 voire même il a eu des
agissements similaires en 2005 qui avait
découvert et la société générale était
informé de ces agissements en 2000
7 et en matière de licenciement
lorsqu'on fait un licenciement pour
faute disciplinaire qu'elle soit simple
ou qu'elle soit grave on doit engager
cette procédure de licenciement dans les
deux mois de la connaissance des faits
fautifs alors c'est vrai qu'il ya un
paradoxe entre une prescription qui est
trois ans pour des délits c'est à dire
appartement on sait que quelqu'un comme
bien des lions à trois ans pour
poursuivre en matière d'ogm en matière
de droit du travail en admirant le feu
nomme bon donc
les prud'hommes ont estimé sur la base
des documents qui ont été versées aux
débats que la société générale avait
connaissance des faits fautifs
depuis 2007 et qu'il fallait qu'elle
engage si elle devenait en 2005 et demi
et 2 ne te renouveler en 2007
donc la société générale elle a combattu
en disant pas du tout on savait qu'en
ha ha bon voilà le conseil des
prud'hommes a estimé donc il nous le
conseil des prud'hommes n'est même pas
les regarder la qualification de faute
grave ou pas retenu par d'ailleurs par
les juges pénaux mais a simplement dit
pas trop tard vous avez tiré quand vous
avez tiré le licenciement ça faisait
plus de deux mois vous étiez au courant
donc il ya un article du code du travail
qui prévoit sa très clairement vous avez
deux mois pour le faire vous avez pas
rester peut-être le délai de deux mois
l'humour ou votre licenciement est sans
cause réelle et sérieuse
voilà le fond mais c'est pas beau pas ce
qu'est ce que j'entends bien ce que vous
des coûts même il ya derrière ce
jugement l'idée que la société générale
était quand même au courant des années
c'est la gare motivations du jugement
c'est la société générale qu'ils avaient
et donc quand même ça extrêmement
favorable mais d'albias pour ces
titres est fait alors il la fille c'est
très favorable pour l'audience de la
semaine prochaine oui puisque dire
'attendez 5 milliards de
dommages-intérêts alors qu'ils étaient
au courant oui s'il ya un appel sur ce
jugement là il n'en demeure pas moins
que alors je sais pas comment le cour
d'appel de versailles va là-bas statut
et là dessus du buisson patron de ce
fait général
après la condamnation de kerviel avait
dit bien évidemment nous ne demandons
jamais à kerviel de rembourser ce qu'ils
y aillent on prendra juste ce site
radoteur seulement deux réseaux peu de
chance bien évidemment c'est une somme
impossible à un bourses et pour
quiconque donc bien évidemment on n'aura
jamais le remboursement de cinq
milliards après moi j'ose espérer que
bien évidemment la société générale et
tout courant sera extrêmement inquiétant
vous dire que une banque soit pas au
courant gâté puisse miser autant
d'argent à ça ce serait une preuve
d'incompétence et de l'incurie de la
part de toute cette banque qui sera
folle entre un jeune et faudrait que
tout le monde retire son argent de la
banque si c'est vrai s'ils continuent et
des actions concourant sais c'est pas la
banque dans lequel faut aller à mon avis
le racisme au courant ça change quand
même l'équipe et quand même courbe et
tout ça sur un autre plan mais sur un
plan purement économique si ça me
rassure qu'ils sont au courant
il n'a fait un procès en révision sur la
partie pénale enfin voir oui donc ça
peut servir aussi à la vidéo même si la
révision ça commencera un nom oui c'est
rare exceptionnel innocents qui n'ont
jamais réussi à faire rejeter par
rapport à fait vous avez vu les
personnalités les plus puissantes du
monde il n'y a pas ça brink au sein de
dents c'est une erreur d'édition patrice
j'y suis n'ont ils pas messieurs numéro
deux il n'y a pas beaucoup de français
la première c'est angela merkel depuis
des années hillary clinton
christine lagarde qui est la seule
française s'est pas beaucoup s'il a
beaucoup d'influencé en tête chez elle
mais non c'est vrai quelqu'un qui ait
jamais décider quoi que ce soit donc non
c'est pas un français en tout cas qui
exerce un pouvoir exécutif
alors après l'agrégation semaine ça mais
quelle serait la place de ces dix femmes
les plus puissantes dans le tableau des
personnalités des 20 personnalités les
plus puissantes
est ce qu'elles sont les cette dernière
après 13 bon sommes pas face aux as que
ses mixes et ça n'a pas d'intérêt sont à
un gala merkel souvent en tête
il me semble donner une perf et les plus
puissantes et mais oui c'est vrai que la
seule française s'est en effet christine
lagarde tous ces classements enfin c'est
le l'amour du reinking du ranking du
vieillissement
on veut tous classés donc pour pour
vendre on fait des classements j'ai un
classement que j'aime beaucoup c'est la
personnalité préférée des français
yannick noah qui côtoie simone veil réel
mais met en concurrence avec eva kjer
c'est une liste fermée les gg a déjà vu
ça il va c'est pas des gens qui dévoile
à bassam est intègre la liste est
exhaustive
rires parmi les dons qu'ils sont par les
ont choisis parmi une liste de gens
logique et cohérente il ya une liste de
80 personnes connaissaient pas un
chercheur peint un écrivain pas oui
j'avais lancé d'équivalent pour le pour
les jeunes et j'avais à peu près la même
méthodologie que tu ne peux pas qu'on
peut pas demander comme ça ex nihilo qui
vous aimez bien ce que sinon ça va être
stéphane mans sont aux mains de foot
marqué l'année bien sûr donc décidé ça
ça papa voilà les enfants dont comprend
les cartes entre 80 et 150 ke ca de la
gare des clubs l'air est connu dans
différents domaines après alors est ce
que vous connaissez des millenium mais
les millennials ce qui s'est passé
quelques uns
une experte en ligne à six et quatre
d'entre eux jusqu'en 1993 1980 jusqu'à
c'est la génération y qui soutient
charles british d'enfants de platini
l'ami ben oui c'est ça c'est un
président a même
c'est après la génération 98 et là ils
sont très mûrs aux saisons dans une
étude sur les les
les valeurs et leurs convictions
personnelles et regarder les tableaux
alors 56 % ont déjà refusé
catégoriquement de travailler pour une
entreprise ne plaisait pas 55% estiment
que leurs convictions personnelles sont
déterminantes lors d'une prise de
décision au travail et 49% ont déjà
refusé une mission qui ne leur
paraissait pas moral qui ne leur
paraissait pas correspondant à leur
valeur n'est pas que ça change et ça
aussi le rapport travail
c'est inquiétant si vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et avait un type est
maintenant une mission elle a refusé
ça lui plaît pas ça me sourit john dans
ce cas là cette gêne a aussi ils sont
bons sont très flexibles et ce qu on
fait travailler quand même dans les
entreprises et qu'ils ont cet âge là
quand même ils ont aussi un rapport à la
hiérarchie rapport au développement de
projets un rapport au travail et
particuliers
qui confirme également des éléments qui
sont dans dans le dos que vous avez
établi là donc par exemple comprendriez
très bien qu'un à nouveau employé jeune
trouve que votre programmation
précisément passionnant qu'il ya un
une pièce qui ne choque un peu et que
disent non ça je ne travaille pas sûr si
je ne comprends pas je recherche je
l'observais seulement parce que c'est
difficile je veux dire ma journée un
jour n'ait eu des jeunes de cet âge là
et c'est difficile il serait pas dans
une culture d'entreprise
il n'en est pas créer une réelle et non
pas créer une réelle culture
d'entreprise non plus et donc ils sont
un petit peu là où ils sont bien ou là
comme il aime bien ou là comme ça va
bien si vous vous laissez pas
effectivement ça donne ça donc c'est
très surprenant
j'étais pas en train de le cautionner
j'étais inscrite seulement de l'observer
ce don que vous posez la question je
réponds bah non c'est très ennuyeux ce
que vous dites c'est pas forcément au
nom de valeurs
c'était plutôt exprimé au nom de valeurs
personnelles des tic des climats aussi
auxquels ils sont sensibles ils n'ont
pas vraiment envie de travailler comme
ceux ci préférerait à travailler comme
cela mais quand vous leur dites
d'organiser les choses bah finalement
non il voit pas pourquoi ce serait à eux
de les organiser un congrès c'est
compliqué donc une façon de se
positionner qui est très
particulièrement de management
voilà alors je ne sais pas ce qui va se
donner comme manager dans danse haka 10
ans est intéressant c'est intéressant
c'est vrai qu'il ya un rapport qui
changent enfin qu'ils seront un peu au
delà par le même pas la pyramide sera
plus trop de pire à lomé les mêmes de la
transversalité comment ils vont gérer
les choses parce que justement je pense
qu'ils ont sur des valeurs ou des des
choses oui que sur lesquels ils ne
veulent pas céder ou
with estime que ça va faire partie de
leur vie comme ça parce que d'un côté on
a l'air de dire allez à l'oil qu'aubry
enfin on est en plein dans le débat que
le travail de plus en plus précaire
qu'il faut fermer sa gueule euros si on
veut si on veut rester dans son emploi
or ces sauvages pour que c'est le
contraire quoi qu'il se passe avec les
jeunes en tout cas pour une grosse
partie d'entre eux j'imagine qu'ils
soutiennent aussi à 150% les donneurs
d'alerté devrait donc c'est plutôt pas
mal c'est plutôt rassurant
moi je pensais aussi ou alors au jeune
en politique c'est vrai qu'il y en a pas
beaucoup
mais les jeunes en politique ceux qui
sont un peu visible je trouve qu'ils
sont parfois pires que les aînés en
matière de langue de bois en matière de
carriérisme de professionnalisation de
la politique et c'est là moi je suis pas
je suis pas spécialement optimiste même
si un discours sur l'éthique les valeurs
etc
mais donc c'est pas parce qu'on est
jeune et je parle en connaissance de
cause
ça n'est malade mais bien sûr c'est un
état de marion la jeunesse ça n'est pas
parce qu'on est jeune que nécessairement
on éthique moral et qu'on est meilleur
que les vieux même si c'est vrai la
société réserve pas une place de choix à
sa jeunesse objet d'un autre débattre
mais ces chiffres là moi enfin me me
rassure plutôt mais aussi m'interroge
sur qui sont génération y d'accord la
génération y manger d'accord pays parce
qu'ils portaient leur casque branché
vont ils feraient bien de débrancher
aussi un peu pris de temps en temps mais
donc je suis assez sceptique sur ces
quand même sur ses études
ces sondages ici c'est du cdh une espèce
de ranking seulement soit pas très bien
vu comme ça je n'ai pas compris c'est
pourquoi s'appelait me millenia ce mail
et knowles succès lors de scènes pas se
perdre et c'est pas le nom s'est passé
par rapport à aigle en 2006
ce qu'avait 20 en 2000 ou un truc comme
ça je me sens bien en 2000 ils ont bien
servi maintenant et non mais enfin non
mais on se sent très vieux je trouve là
maintenant tout de suite passé en otage
un bon pas passé à la politique et bio
finira pas ben par la voilà on ne suis
pas un fou de foot
voyez pas les troubles politiques non y
aller ce coup ci ça c'était face à vous
de vous intéresser que françois hollande
proposerait dans le programme qu'il va
mettre sur pied pour sa réélection en
2010 est la suppression du poste de
premier ministre
et c'est vrai qu'on a un nom mais on a
assez peu bizarrement de débats
institutionnels en france alors que tout
le monde voit quand même que les
institutions de la vème république ce ne
sont peut-être plus celles qui sont
adaptés situation actuelle je pense
plutôt le contraire vous êtes très
favorable à ces institutions je crois
pas nécessairement mais je trouve qu'on
a trop débat institutionnel avant
justement et que on en oublie
l'essentiel les débats institutionnels
celles contenant et on en oublie le
contenu le contenu c'est une affaire de
confiance entre les élus et le corps
électoral de confiance dans les
institutions et ce à des textes
fusse-t-il constitutionnel ne peuvent
pas nécessairement tout faire alors
supprimer le premier ministre c'est pas
une idée neuve
on en parle depuis ça veut dire quoi
présidentialiser ça veut dire oui ça
veut que ça signifie alors ça signifie
que donc il ya plus de premier ministre
et un gouvernement qui en gros est
dirigé par le président de la république
mais ça veut dire aussi qu'on retire au
régime sa nature parlementaire c'est à
dire que le président de la république
perd le pouvoir de dissoudre l'assemblée
et ladite assemblée par le pouvoir
réciproquement de renverser le
gouvernement
alors on a affaire un résident un régime
dit présidentiel tel qu'il est instaurée
aux états unis d'amérique
oui ça change beaucoup à ça ressemble
beaucoup sur le papier et on a plutôt
tendance à dire c'est bien parce que
c'est
ces américains mais sauf que la france
ça n'est pas les états unis et que les
systèmes institutionnels sont le
résultat de culture d'histoire de moeurs
de conception et que l'importation ou
l'exportation d'un régime elle est très
complet donc je suis assez encore une
fois sceptique sur cette question là
d'autant que ça enlèverait au chef de
l'état
comment dirais-je sa conception un peu
gaullienne si vous voulez le présent de
la république en ressortirait me
semble-t-il assez affaibli l'institution
présidentielle soit pas du président
actuel est de surcroît je ne pense pas
qu'il soit dans la culture politique
française que nous soyons capables de
faire fonctionner un régime
institutionnel sans ce pivot central
quel premier ministre promu nice c'est
aussi nous n'oublions pas une fusi bhl
qui peut sauter en cours de nos navires
dans le quinquennat quand même bien le
c'est vrai que le club rhénan j'ai eu
des gammes sur le devant de la scène
bien sûr hélas bien sûr ne pas se cacher
au fond il l'est beaucoup trop parce que
le présent la république sous le
quinquennat il est grillé très vite très
vite aussi vite que prévu au civil que
le premier était néanmoins remplaçable
qu'un produit est mise à jour sur le
débat social non mais je trouve ça très
intéressant c'est effectivement un
rééquilibrage parce qu'on parle beaucoup
quand murray qui livrent âge des
pouvoirs entre le président entre
l'exécutif et les législatives
c'est là aussi c'est pareil je il ya un
très grand auteur alors qu'ils
s'appelaient guy carcassonne connaissait
bien sûr des professeurs à paris 10 qui
est décédé il ya pas longtemps et ils
disaient ils avaient raison que le
parlement il a depuis longtemps tous les
moyens si les utiliser pour avoir des
pouvoirs importants
sauf qu'il les utilise pas ou peu pour
des raisons politiques essentiellement à
cause du fait majoritaire fait
majoritaire qui est pas mal fissurer en
ce moment et là c'est
institutionnellement intéressant mais
voilà revaloriser la situation du
parlement on a déjà fait encore faut-il
que les parlementaires se serre la
concordance des élections facilite pas
quand même
l'autonomie des deux pouvoirs mais ça a
été un désastre à la réforme jospin
était un désastre de ce point de vue la
fin de la semaine
non mais parce qu'il y avait aussi dans
tout ce que j'ai pu lire et entendre une
modification du sénat en étant aidé
assemblée avec les collectivités
territoriales
donc c'est ce que j'ai lu c'est qu'on
n'en parlait pas là parce
qu'effectivement il ya un pouvoir de
l'assemblée nationale qui semblerait
être accrue avec objectivement le
rééquilibrage des pouvoirs mais du coup
c'est la saison les sénatoriales qu'il
serait présent tant de régions eh ben
oui mais alors que l'on a refondé notre
territoire national avec une
territorialisation différente avec ses
principes de grandes régions
d'intercommunalité qui vont devenir tout
ça ça va devenir prédominant et
financièrement et dans les politiques
diverses et variées on retrouve là
peut-être un endroit pour faire voilà je
me questionnais enfin parce que je n'ai
pas d'une question que de gaulle avait
posée aux français en 1969 sur lequel il
a perdu
amusant d'essayer de faire de la
politique fiction en imaginant à quel
niveau de popularité à quel niveau
politique on serait arrivé hollande
s'ils s'étaient passés le premier
ministre ici la réforme qui semble
appeler ses voeux étaient mis en place
depuis début juin qu'elle a payé
l'épargné rodez nival c'est est-ce que
ce geste qui ont jusque là c'est de
l'art enfin voila c'est une question
mais qui a ses raisons quand même
d'accord
vous savez on parle on parle de réformes
institutionnelles quand on veut pas
parler d'autre chose
seulement mais enfin moi je trouve que
pour ben on n'a pas eu lieu si vous avez
raison y ait des débats ma fille il
reste un peu lettre morte et a eu
quelques réformes constitutionnelles oui
mais c'est compliqué je dis pas là
encore que les gens sont pas aptes à
comprendre mais c'est compliqué de
lancer les débats dans la société sur ce
thème et deux danseurs dos il oublie ça
si vous dis je vais supprimer le prévu
liste comme nous l'a expliqué ça veut
dire que le président aura en réalité un
peu moins de pouvoir mais pour les gens
ça veut dire il va prendre tous les
pouvoirs acceptant leurs titres à
l'offre et non écoutés ballon
heureusement on n'a pas le temps paraît
de la furent eliasson qui est à
versailles que vous avez vu
sabine hic est que et que vous avez
adoré le monde disait et le monde disait
il n'a pas tort que c'est peut-être
l'artiste qui va le mieux
oui peut-être de plusieurs crises et il
à versailles
jean-charles bon c'est même plus que tu
écoutes je suppose
non non non non moi j'aimais j'aimais
beaucoup geffrouais facem toujours
instructif
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que le ces de
l'eau s'était essayée du médecin donc ça
allait voir olafur eliasson
et quand même vous passionner pour
l'euro aussi les efforts et après vous
lisez un nouveau mineur et commencer par
le goût de 1923 et on aura une critique
la prochaine fois labine que ça et puis
et vous twittez puis je verrai les
résultats de 0,7 merci beaucoup à tous
les kappa frais bas c'est fini mais ça
va recommencer un jour